okay okay it's a voice I kept a bow and
we're back we're back
what is that in a man of Mad Dog last we
saw I think sure we're getting [ __ ]
around that's all I'm gonna say things
were gonna [ __ ] well I think Conrad
escaped on the boat [ __ ] yeah and I
think they were actually like they ran
into the giant ship the ghost ship you
know I'm saying progress people
everyone's just we're a lot
[ __ ]
but [ __ ] is that
go
it's [ __ ] going let's say this [ __ ]
you say it can't imagine I'm [ __ ]
dark it must be in there I think I
process [ __ ] Jesus
yeah
[ __ ]
oh very had a [ __ ] walk
oh yeah la ones here
Oh [ __ ] this
can I read this hey Paul the [ __ ]
music is so [ __ ] loud [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] SFX I've [ __ ] allowed too
there we go
let's [ __ ] do this
this whole place is a floating deathtrap
she said
so I supposed to go why am I looking at
you like that hello sir
a chef danger Sabine dehydrate now I'm
saying what's over here
yeah how's it go look
I'm asking for Atmos do you dare look
down yeah
side match I did
they're freaked out about Oh what the
[ __ ] is this whoa right now I don't know
I asked you a
Caribe
[ __ ] look at that
[ __ ] Mouse a mouse Tara memorandum
like it was a [ __ ] say you covering
Patterson's guard to you tomorrow second
came conveniently it's always when it's
guard to use it in hold three a he's
courteous in all three a first to 2400
check jeff rotation okay yeah it's the
third times a week none of us like it
down I'm ready Patterson should buck up
just get on it three a what a [ __ ]
stalled out huh I guess she doesn't like
abandon [ __ ] rides
also you're going to see okay
the [ __ ] you're the key to that
Valley know that kind to cut
step
I know shows this fit they're all fit
what the hell is this [ __ ] place and
now it that says it asked to have
something to do with the mentorian gold
we're not far from those coordinates
maybe this is the ship that was carrying
the gold yes it's a possibility and now
can't just sit around need a plan we
need loot some [ __ ] get back to our boat
get the hell away from here and never
step foot off dry land again how's that
for a plan I saw one of the goons take
something out of the boat
this tributary cap makes the engine work
the do give me a line it's a floating
bridge without it we need to get it back
I'm panning for manchurian gold or
whatever they think they're gonna find
on this floating coffin we gotta take
advantage and look around for a way out
of here the [ __ ] is Eric I just wanted
to see
I might have gotten things kind of wrong
back there excuse me
I may have kind of prematurely come to
the conclusion that maybe you know
you're working some kind of side deal
with these guys mash yes but I I mean
obviously that's not true they're being
just as bad to you as they are to us
yeah allow me to translate he's saying
that he's sorry well I well your apology
is kinda accepted now she's working for
them cuckoo
I got no idea stop asking me here is
this hey babe a though mushy like crazy
to miss J Rivera
in Kentucky three months on to my next
sleeve and jumping into her arms three
months I've been on some surely but the
skies have your bears don't work you're
my keeping everything ready for you
because reminds drift whoa how's work of
the bossy you leave me alone I can take
yourself did it guy eller guarding dark
and spooky down there so guys to see a
figure roaming around
ok ok
it's over here more take their way
[ __ ] it is very strange [ __ ] pair of
glasses what's wrong with it
they're wrong with them what's so
strange about them okay
okay so it's over here
that's over here
oh [ __ ] okay
I kind of like there's no like tensou
feel to when I tap right looks first
thing I do it once it's not working
don't I pray or anything that I'm like
fighting anything that you come on yeah
retail like Englund I missing when they
said it'd go unearthing to what I don't
know what okay how Paco
now the [ __ ] all over here did their
[ __ ] out that's what she said
yeah
okay
what's going on out there
I don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about talk about watching
[ __ ]
what is this
duck [ __ ] mascot he's cat
the SS
the [ __ ] was that all that high pitch
okay let me let me see if I get the
whole now did he get through fetch
what's taking so long
that's really keep the snails maybe we
can open and get out of here make a lot
of [ __ ] noise I picked this could be
the way out create a distraction
wait wait maybe we should try
barricading the door instead nah let's
make a distraction cuz I would then we
one live at a time
[Music]
[Music]
okay 90 she should be call right now
she gonna hide in or what
or place
perfect [ __ ] yeah hey where the [ __ ]
they go he's [ __ ] he's [ __ ]
in fact that it got
Oh
lock that [ __ ] n uh yeah he's gonna die
in there yeah the [ __ ] love stairs
[ __ ] love stairs what's over here
what's it here
disgusting
geez maybe this is what's good chase
[ __ ] that scared me [ __ ] rat [ __ ]
rat on another one gonna jump out right
now okay so we [ __ ] scary
and it's live on here you take a [ __ ]
live anywhere [ __ ] rats don't trust
rats actually I like rats I got jumped
by rats my out there good children
I got judging
whoa what the [ __ ] was that I had a pan
on its cargo hold too
okay
[ __ ] Carter hotel
scary
the [ __ ] in here
you know skipper
Wow [ __ ] check out this
[ __ ]
lick it Oh
there Ellis come on home la la strada
see anything [ __ ] important here and
because she me a key so his little boy
put in Ted Robert
cat food let's go you [ __ ] know it
next you know it's next [ __ ]
all right I guess I'm going this way
sure thing comrades maybe Oh
yeah yeah yeah
we're gonna wrap that [ __ ] around
it's not bad for pitch snap out of [ __ ]
they won't help me everyone's hiding in
the mood for a big surprise party
that's sick
[ __ ] is that [ __ ] Mouse skull
you're gonna eat on it he's gonna play
with it
[ __ ] there saw them all away when the
animation was too long Joanie Loves
Chachi
I can read that or what yeah
yeah let me say skippers were knocked
out for booze old Jeb get it felt hope
you load the ship what could be in those
boxes
Oh
here we go
it's not gonna look just heard one of
the guys here snuck a look at this box
thing you'll fire and see what he saw
maybe you can help me take a look it's
all set okay
all right let's say here that's all off
the guys that's say anything important
here
we're gonna choke Russia the ones in the
box it no I got there's only [ __ ] two
pages get the [ __ ] out of here
get that [ __ ] out of here
you hear [ __ ] breathing well it's too
much
there is a [ __ ] coming up
it was it upon us oh no it's one of
those things
okay I don't know were that
that's [ __ ] up
the [ __ ] is down here that's what you
want the car gold its car call - [ __ ]
Mouse
turn flash like [ __ ] like [ __ ] even
the flash it reads head Jennifer faucet
[ __ ] the [ __ ]
you know this guy's be fine could see we
just saw premonition [ __ ] shut up this
guy in the same Oh No
that's the [ __ ] cap duck better get
that better yeah
this guy like money or not
okay
this could be our chance
hey stupid [ __ ] he gonna be safe relax
okay who likes me what Brad like saying
yeah where the [ __ ] he went and Joey
likes me bliss yeah because I said that
she was one of them what the [ __ ] are
you doing girl no look higher than it
was okay second Levi's commercial okay
what
[ __ ] hi [ __ ]
if I guess hey she [ __ ] sees him
x-ray
I do creation say don't on this bus
should keep
she was up well sorta sorta yes seventh
batch
you dumb [ __ ] okay
what are we doing I thought we were
following them gotta keep our distance
that's why we can get
[ __ ] go [ __ ] oh no there's some
goodies over there get back here
let me see some of these goodies
all right check it I pick it up
what the [ __ ]
okay let's go [ __ ] figure out
this [ __ ]
hey it's Q yeah that's what we do
nobody knows nobody [ __ ] knows saw it
walk it huh let's keep walking I guess
now we have it have you been here oh
[ __ ]
Oh Alex what is it [ __ ] penis see for
yourself
okay touch it
what is that
they're [ __ ] steak as I
okay
yeah we have a [ __ ] up in here [ __ ] we
got that man
so short metal is Oh as if you know your
way around the kitchen
hey baby once we settle down I will be
your personal chef de cuisine huh
yeah
she's kind of like the chemicals in the
ground they're breathing in this [ __ ]
now what's over there that oh I love
those paintings hey what the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] what's in here
yeah they're never happen none of my
watch [ __ ]
- sweets slow and refresh it
rats probably just rats that's all it
was
yeah don't laugh [ __ ]
it's in this [ __ ] before
are you got that much okay no this isn't
working for me what Rose caskets and
crappy chapels not my scene you know
you're right it's gross and it's crappy
you gotta get out of here too sweet
okay so can we just get the [ __ ] out
then yeah dude
she's loving me actually went up had a
nap [ __ ]
why would I [ __ ] inspect that yeah I
guess what is it jump scared we know it
you got anyone this guy who cares where
they're from or where they're going
oh that's [ __ ] okay
Oh what the [ __ ] you doing did
we need now
no I hate that I need to look deeper
okay the bone buddies
Thank You [ __ ] we got to see more we
gotta say more I want to tell you how
did I'm gonna tell you
well they said jump-scare we got to get
all the junkies one look for a kid or
something I don't want to know
get out of here now
she stayed with [ __ ] got some serious
locks in these caskets why would they be
chained and locked
[Applause]
[Music]
look seriously are you trying to freak
me out can we just get out of here
yeah stupid [ __ ]
what is that sick bay
what's making that sound
my social spick-and-span
otherwise is a [ __ ] and span this is no
time to be [ __ ] around I'm serious I
can't take it you guys lose got a mad
Oh No [ __ ] yeah why did I touch it I why
did the [ __ ] did I touch it touch it
that's fact that
that's I'm [ __ ] up [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here
Barry okay [ __ ] can I go back another
kitchen knife [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's [ __ ]
not great Oh one eye
uh-huh
where are you taking me why would they
yeah all right they say you got a really
good point feel full for asking
the [ __ ] is that
hey back off yes you can
come on
[ __ ]
okay don't even know what you're doing
just do whatever you tell see don't you
yeah the best bells
that's an i pays the bells stop
Oh what is that some shiny over here yes
David [ __ ]
[ __ ] heart navigator rear okay here
we go we're gone this way I just closed
the door behind me like any of these
doors that close behind me [ __ ] jump
scare you seen anything
why don't she was hitting on back out
there
these [ __ ] places twist
yeah
a little called Florence and I like
about it's cursed that [ __ ] had a hat
something Madonn
bearing of the captain's hat
what are you talking about [ __ ]
any cat food in here cat fit like a
[ __ ] party hat on Oh crazy that guys
probably still in here with us
I mean you die on a ship your post stays
on the ship
with no idea what you're talking about
you gonna [ __ ] it
I don't know what the [ __ ] this is all
about but we got to keep moving and find
Olsen now I I kind of gray
yeah yes could you fan
I don't like when it changes directions
they keep pressing forward to go for it
and the second you go through the camera
changes so you keep seeing forward you
actually go backwards he's that painting
real quick Hey
yeah that's gonna check that out okay
[ __ ] about three [ __ ] he end
see question portal
right you're on trucks then
the hell guys [ __ ] tripping should go
find out what that guys doing we all get
a gun
anyway the backtrack yeah I could
probably go and see what's going on
the [ __ ] is that batch okay
the [ __ ] he go
I'm not even gonna [ __ ] ask
not that font truck and hey I was gonna
make it what's over here no no not here
jump-scare [ __ ] jump-scare o'clock
the [ __ ]
that can't be a good sign yeah that's
good very good
it's like well the missus come from
the [ __ ] that shed
and it's that
Jesus what I've been doing here
II
[Music]
[ __ ]
let's guy still good
hello Bradley all right
he overslept
come on
all right right
beat-up II already got that man let's do
this
yeah slip on either [ __ ] present or
or something
wait this is just for us
I can hear just [ __ ] here
okay
I'm talking shortcut over there
I guess not
[ __ ] help us they piece of chalk
right there
this can't be good no this guy there's a
[ __ ] body hanging from the ceiling
right now he's gonna fall gonna [ __ ]
fall isn't it
the [ __ ] is that it's just Julius we're
here okay
they were here
yeah give me a jump-scare man anytime we
got to be a to backtrack you're [ __ ]
that change directions [ __ ]
shiny okay
Oh
like this hammer cuz [ __ ] you're gonna
get [ __ ] up
in there and they're so tough you're so
scary
I'm getting like [ __ ] punished for
not going all the rooms
[ __ ] shamrock yeah what happened here
there's this patch
let me check what's up there
focus at that
I'll brief locker room nod [ __ ] up
just skinny yeah great
how do they loose hadn't supposed to
even so when were [ __ ] real power
that sucked
why would I open that up now [ __ ] now
now
I'm not gonna do it wanna be President I
just but I get the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] is that
[ __ ] Mouse tail
what is this like Regan Emma or
something
respirator filter objective reason
already as gas masks
your toes got a jump out right there but
I guess that mustard guess
maybe they're through here hey are you
gonna maybe get a jump scare yeah why
would you go that route like there's
[ __ ] a million hallways why would you
like
like why would you go through like that
doesn't nice answer hey what's up there
Hey
yeah okay
Alex rabbit from Julia right
[ __ ]
way too quiet [ __ ] jump-scare killer
[ __ ] jump-scare
your [ __ ] now [ __ ] you're [ __ ] now
that's all I gotta say is you're [ __ ]
what is that
one of those things
they [ __ ] saddles or something who's
that who's there
get away
their life vests
[Music]
I'm not hearing this and I hear that
[ __ ] chop down all ice it's over here
quick very key or something
skeletons
skeletons
there's this sort of altercation
gonna [ __ ] grab he's gonna grab your
hand [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
a grad skeleton that open up that door
ain't [ __ ] John went down ain't no
[ __ ] now
going in here now
you know [ __ ] crowbar [ __ ]
can I get that
the [ __ ]
and I see a no weapon now
Alex Julia
Oh
whoa who's that dude
okay curb our [ __ ]
yeah I should gonna turn around here now
fetch bearing updated list in finding
reason the car rolled okay
the bank's Dec folks got
it's kind of [ __ ]
isn't his [ __ ] boxers hey just a desk
on here I don't that that I guess is
guys mine that [ __ ] your luck in this
goddamn I got that you
[ __ ]
this kind of [ __ ]
they got out
yes but that's yet [ __ ] red in here
yeah now what that says [ __ ]
[ __ ] beautiful that's what this is
that [ __ ] is that
very nice match
I've [ __ ] blood on the floor right
here [ __ ] just keep your head on the
street
what is that
the [ __ ] is that that usually
it's [ __ ] a cold Buccaneer at the
[ __ ]
okay blah overplay what the [ __ ] uh I'm
in it
great way to get Tennessee what the [ __ ]
yeah breast test why not
yeah it's like just weird enough I'm
actually scared whatever the [ __ ] this I
saw just [ __ ] do this
yeah just saw blood
no that's [ __ ] wait what is that over
there
[ __ ]
yeah
at [ __ ]
and it's [ __ ] no it's just though what
is that
who else [ __ ] bleeding okay don't
mind man yeah it's got a [ __ ] up
anything over here nice tickets over
here dad just giant waste that time over
there
[ __ ] afraid of
Wow Jake see get some [ __ ] fresh air
that water
ensuring gold
what the [ __ ]
I stuck okay there we go what the [ __ ]
going on here
the same exact ready
can't put that again
very sick that's the [ __ ] is just a
[ __ ]
Oh
that's [ __ ]
that is [ __ ]
this really thing I collapsed
is that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] see there's the guy again
Brad
Hey right
hey what's wrong what are you doing
oh I shoved that bar
whoa
where's that [ __ ]
what a filthy [ __ ] who's that like the
bad chemicals oh my god back in the boat
again with mr. al
make up here so they don't know
what is that Oh scary
the [ __ ]
candy
Abra hey bruh
you gotta make it a session
[Music]
bad wretch
[ __ ] I don't remember who was drowning
where's
wife
you okay
Thanks I could have drowned
it cut it better
wait what the [ __ ]
that's him
[Music]
let's go
see a weird hybrid thing did the [ __ ]
guys like [ __ ] morphing
3:11 Thank You pockets left
he's here what's the matter tree both
[Music]
he's like oh oh
I think I said let his feet
what is sweet
if you were over
shut [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
fight back [ __ ]
we got him what the [ __ ]
foot oh thank god
yeah it's me come on let's go Jesus we
gotta get sober sake
oh we all made it
Cina breathe easy yeah good here I think
yeah we'll be all right here
yeah we did it
Oh No
things appear to have taken a turn
towards the spiritual wouldn't you say
I would say so yes very skinny this guy
have you figured out what's going on how
to stop it how to save the lives of your
poor unfortunate stowaways yeah yeah you
will I hope although it seems the ships
previous occupants never managed to
quite a lot of deaths
let me help you out give you a little
hint
can't make up your mind a pity
and dangerous
perhaps you've started to realize
something what everything and everyone
may not be quite what they appear to be
I hope that helps
well aren't you excited to find out what
your poor unfortunates are making of all
this and how you might avoid any more
unnecessary tragedy go on back to it
thank you
yeah I like this shirt okay thanks guys
I say y'all the next one now hope you
had a good one thank ya